Let's go next to our color from the six one
nine area code. Who's calling today from six
one nine.
I think it's me. Can you hear me?
Yes. Who's this?
So let me give me, um, I have the biggest
pleasure wherever meeting you. My name's Besley
dollaring. [inaudible]
your name is Valerie [inaudible].
Yes, I worry and blaming and I'm still happy
to. Finally, you have been watching the news
since I can't even tell you when I have a
question. We've already, for example, I have
so many questions, but you, you, you are a
journalist and I started watching you way
back then. Right? But then you already have
physically like to be your journalist or did
you just start going out and like do things
on your own life the way that you have been
now on YouTube?
I started the show when I was 21 in college,
so I was not working in media at the time
that I started the show.
But it's so amazing. So then how did you,
you know, how did you learn all the things
that you've learned? How, how is they now
that you get to go and interview and like
have these amazing things that you do? How
did you do it?
It's a lot of learn by doing. You just each
day you try to do it a little bit better.
A lot of reading, a lot of practice. Uh, it's,
it's been a, it's been a learn on the job
sort of thing for me.
What, what has what resources, like for example,
me, I don't mean you have much money right
now and I'm not really technically employed
but I really would love to do things like
this. You know, like, like how you get to
interview and stuff. How, how can I get my
foot in the door just to do this has the self
like on anything both. Like there's so many
things that we still don't know about. For
example, like you know how it saves the slightly
mentioned things about the drug crisis, homelessness,
they do mention it on the news, but it's kind
of slight and I feel like we should get to
know more the people's problems of how one
thing is correlated with the other. Certain
social problems are just not on the news as
they should be. And therefore I feel like
politicians don't talk about it as much as
it should be and therefore there's more priority.
So these type of issues that are actually
either everything in our life.
Yes. And the question was how can you get
involved in media
[inaudible] like yeah, as a citizen, like
say like me, I'm broke. How, how can someone
like me who is fro cool, you know, how can
I just volunteer or give my time or in learning,
you know, I just want to be able to do this.
Right. Well two options, the way I started
was at a community radio station in Massachusetts
where you just show up and they often have
sliding scale fees where you can just start
learning and it doesn't cost you anything.
So look to see if there's a community radio
station in your area. But the great thing
about if you, I'm guessing you have a phone
since you're calling me on the phone, you
can even use your phone to start citizen journalism
and citizen activism. So unfortunately the
barriers to entry have been drastically reduced.
Uh, and it's an exciting time. Uh, Valerie,
I so appreciate the call and I hope to hear
from you again. Great to hear from you. Let's
go next to our caller from the five Oh five
area code. Who's calling today from five Oh
five.
Hey David, this is Isaiah from Albuquerque.
Hey, um, I actually just had a quick question,
um, in regards to, um, my prediction or, and
definitely hope is that burning takes, uh,
the primary, but if he ends up going up against
Trump and the general election and ended up
losing, I'm curious how um, progressive might
refocus strategically future elections or
how do you think something like that would
affect political strategy for the progressive
left?
Well, we talked about this on a segment a
few weeks ago where we, I laid out how, if
you look at the, if you kind of game out the
different scenarios, Bernie is the nominee
and wins. Bernie is the nominee and loses
a centrist is the nominee and wins, or a centrist
is the nominee and loses. If Bernie is the
nominee and loses to Trump, not only will
Republicans say this is a rejection of left
social democracy, even the centrist democratic
party will say, this has been a rejection
of centrist of a, of a left social democracy,
and we should never again elect someone like
Bernie to be the nominee in the first place.
So I think that until it happens, we're not
really going to know the repercussions, but
there is no doubt that, so if Bernie fails
to be the nominee, then you will have the
democratic party saying, see, we told you
that those ideas weren't viable to be the
nominee. If Bernie is the nominee but loses
the Trump, they will say, see, we told you
that even if the democratic party selected
Bernie as the nominee, that these ideas would
lose to Trump nationally. So no matter what,
they are going to react in that way. The specific
way in which it will happen is we were sort
of in a wait and see on that.
Definitely. Do you, do you believe that it
would show any sort of, I'm out of touch,
miss, so to speak from the left, if Bernie
loses in the sense that um, there's a real
big, um, platform that it's grassroots diverse
and it's really what the people want as far
as policy go. Um, but maybe it would just
be enlightening in some sense and expose some,
um, sort of misunderstandings that we might
have. The U S populace as a whole thing you
have to remember
is when half the country doesn't vote, you
can have policies that are popular with 75%
of the country, but based on who chooses to
go out and vote for and against the policies,
they might only be represented say 45% at
the ballot box, even though they might represent
75% of all Americans, and so it's tricky and
dangerous too.
Extract
[inaudible] too much from that because half
the country or 45% of the country doesn't
even vote.
Definitely. Yeah, that's a fair point. Yeah,
unfortunately, but well, thank you for taking
my questions, David. I'm a big thing.
Thanks Isaiah. Alcove to hear from you again.
Let's take a quick break. We are going to
take more calls right after this short break,
so if you're currently holding, please don't
hang up because we are getting right back
to the calls momentarily.